believes in the intercession of saints
asking them to pray on behalf of the
living the Bible teaches direct prayer
to God without the need for intercession
for there is one God and one mediator
between God and man the man Christ Jesus
First Timothy 2:5 according to him 1
Timothy 2:5 says you pray directly to
God and there is no need for
intercession all
right whenever someone quotes 1 Timothy
2:5 to argue this way then you know this
man or this woman is a Bible butcherer
Andor biblically illiterate does not
know the Bible does not know the context
okay why do I say that okay here let me
shock you okay this what he quoted right
he said no intercession pay attention he
said this passage shuts down
intercession this passage shuts down
inter session
okay according to him it's what he said
right all right now watch watch here
let's see what happens first let's look
at the passage and then we'll read
context for there is one God and there
is one mediator between God and man the
man Christ Jesus right there may the
Holy Spirit who's our teacher teach us
how not to interpret scripture how to
interpret scripture first question to
ask yourselves do you see that word for
that word for indic
indicates that this is a continuation of
Paul's thought inspired by the Holy
Spirit meaning you don't begin at verse
five you have to read the previous
verses to see what the context is
because notice it says for learn how to
interpret your Bible that word indicates
that Paul is continuing the thought of
the previous verses so if I want to know
what the previous verses are I have to
read them in order to understand why he
began this sentence with
four
right now let me show you something guys
let me show you how it begins are you
ready he said this shows no intercession
right okay here it is 1 Timothy 2:1
first of all then I urge that
supplications prayers
intercessions end of story
the context begins with an
exhortation to believers who are united
to the Lord Jesus Christ to supplicate
intercede for the Salvation of others
it's right there how are you going to
use 1 Timothy 2:5 to show pray directly
to God because intercession is not
needed when the point of the passage
is you should intercede and supplicate
for the Salvation of others
because the Lord God desires the body of
Jesus Christ Our Lord to
intercede and pray for the Salvation of
others knowing that your intercession
will be accepted because of the
mediatorship of the Lord Jesus Christ
let's not quote the
context let's read it together to show
you what it means and what it does not
mean
okay to show you what it means what it
does not mean first of all then I urge
that supplications to supplicate invoke
prayers intercessions Thanksgiving be
made for all men for kings and all who
are in high positions that we may lead a
quiet and Peaceable
life Godly and respectful in every way
now
watch now we're going to read what comes
up why why does God want you to do that
here it is slowly but surely we're going
to open up
context here's the reason notice that
word four again verses 3 and four this
is good and acceptable in the sight of
God so God accepts and is pleased when
you do this what is God pleased with and
what does God accept when you the church
pray and intercede for the Salvation of
others who desires all men to be saved
see he wants you to pray for all men
because he wants wants to save all men
and he's going to save all men through
your prayers and
evangelism that all men be saved and
come to the knowledge of the truth now
we get to verse five for there is one
God and there's one mediator between God
and Men the man Christ Jesus now we get
the
context okay now we understand what the
context
is for there is one God and one mediator
between God and Men the man Christ Jesus
and here's verse six so you understand
what he's saying so we can break it down
as the Holy Spirit saves us from
error okay who gave himself as a ransom
for all the testimony to which was born
at the proper time now do you want to
know the
proper explanation of 1 Timothy 2:5 now
that we read the context verses 5 and
six stating the obvious since we know
the Lord Jesus Christ offered his life
his soul as a ransom to redeem all men
from their bondage to sin Satan and
death that's what he
did therefore we know God wants all men
to be saved otherwise Jesus would not
die as a sacrifice offer his soul his
human life as a ransom to emancipate all
men to set humans free all humans free
from bondage to sin Satan and death if
God didn't want all men to be saved so
number one we know God wants all men to
be saved why because the Lord Jesus
Christ died for the Salvation of all men
the second thing since now we know God
wants all men to be saved therefore he
wants the body of Jesus Christ Our Lord
to pray for the Salvation of all
men and you know your prayers will be
efficacious and accepted because you
have a mediator the Lord Jesus who
mediates between God and Men Who because
of your union with him will make your
prayers and intercession acceptable to
God so that when you pray in Union with
the Lord Jesus Christ for the Salvation
of someone no God Delights in that
prayer and desires to answer that
prayer you understand what he's saying
in other words Paul is saying our Lord
being the one
mediator authorizes
us authorizes
us to now pray and intercede for others
because being his body his hands and
feet
mouthpiece United to him we know he's
die the
death necessary to save all men and he
mediates for those who come to
him
repented confessing their sin desire ing
God to be merciful so now what this
passage is actually telling you is be
encouraged our lord Jesus is the one
mediator who through your prayers will
bring about the salvation of all those
that he died for it's not excluding your
intercession it's encouraging you to
intercede because we have a mediator who
reconciles God and men who died that all
men be saved and therefore wants you his
to now pray for their
salvation you understand what it's
saying here so you understand the
passage is teaching the opposite point
of these Bible Butcher and Heretics it's
telling
you you have all the more reason and
confidence to intercede for the
Salvation of
people because you have that one
mediator that you're United to and
because of your union with will make
your prayers acceptable to God to bring
you about the salvation of all men
because the Lord Jesus guaranteed the
salvation of all men by dying for them